going from the side hustle season to
becoming a full-time content creator
does not happen by accident it takes
strategy
and planning and in today's episode
we're jumping into
part two of our how to become a
full-time youtube creator
and sean cannell is going to be breaking
down two critical steps
to actually going full time what does it
take when you are in a season of life
where your schedule doesn't align with
your goals we're going to be covering
that
and more on today's episode of the think
marketing podcast my name is heather
torres and i
am your host and if you're new here we
deliver a brand new podcast
every tuesday so make sure you subscribe
wherever you're listening to this
content right now
and i'm excited because today's episode
is part two
of this three-part series if you missed
part one make sure you go back
and listen to that here on the podcast
and then jump back in here
on part two but let's do a little recap
first part one we talked all about
starting and skilling up now i love what
sean said about starting he said
success on youtube is found when you use
your experience
passion and skills to add real value to
the lives of others
you've got to start before you're ready
but you don't want to just create
content for content's sake
you want to make sure you're creating
content that brings value to other
people
step number two was skilling up you want
to master
your topic you want to get better than
you were yesterday
become obsessed with your subject and
invest
in yourself learning those hard and soft
skills are
critical for your development when it
comes to becoming a full-time content
creator
and in today's episode we're jumping
into step number three
and four step number three is
synergizing
your schedule what does it look like
when you have dreams and goals
but your calendar isn't lining up with
that and
how do you create smart systems i am all
about systems and i'm going to talk
about that
after sean's training here on the
podcast all right step three
synergize your schedule synergize
your schedule synergize your schedule
means this
aligning your jobs hobbies
volunteering and free time
with your end goal so
if you have an end goal full time on
youtube
creating a living
from your passion turning your
creativity into a career
profiting from your passion if you know
that's your target
then you'll get there quicker if you try
to position yourself in a job and if
your hobbies are this and let me know in
the comments
is this your hobby i mean i'm sure i
know you're probably as passionate about
youtube as me
so maybe youtube is your hobby that's a
good thing right because then your hobby
is also
like this thing you're doing on the side
so if your job is leveling you up and
your hobbies are moving you towards your
gear
goal and you're volunteering somewhere
and that's moving you towards your goal
and you're taking your free time and by
the way this might seem hardcore
but hey you're here and it's this is you
know it's one point of view
but i am a firm believer
in extreme sacrifice
for a short period of time so that you
can
experience success for the rest of your
life
i heard dave ramsey put it this way live
today like no one else so that later in
life
you can live like no one else i'm
experiencing that right now
why because of this it's hardcore but my
hobbies my jobs my volunteering it was
all a light so
so i was on like this fast track because
i i was just like i know that this is
like the north star like somehow i'm
gonna be full time on youtube
i'm gonna figure this stuff out let me
try to stack everything
because again and if this is out of your
control
it's out of your control if certain
parts of your schedule are unchangeable
then they're unchangeable
but i'm talking about what you can
control what you can influence right
it's a power principle right there so
this
introduces us to the proximity principle
now my friend ken coleman
just dropped this new book but here's
the principle and i highly recommend it
i'll link it up in the youtube
description
it's a book about the proven strategy
that will lead to the career you love
but here is what the proximity principle
is finding opportunities to do what you
love
is as simple as getting around the right
people and being in the right
places okay so the gist of the book
and the proximity principle itself is
saying okay
where do i want to go in my life and
once you've defined that
and maybe it's just one target full time
on youtube okay
what people then and places what people
could i put myself around
which could happen through podcasts
youtube videos
books that is one way because you're
getting around them you're getting their
thinking their mindset
but if you can actually get around them
by volunteering by working for them or
whatever
and then what places like what
environments or events
or or volunteer if you get around the
right people in places
boom it just accelerates you into
that desired end goal that you're
going for and so remember the two
thousand jobs and
ten jobs and pr uh projects red robin by
the way
not so much the prox not so much the
synergy
i had to pay the bills and what i loved
about red robin was i found one vehicle
where i could work three days and i
worked thursday friday and saturday
and i worked 10 to 12 hour shifts and i
only worked three days a week and i
doubled
all those shifts and i stacked all that
money so i could do church stuff sunday
monday
tuesday and wednesday and youtube so
everything we were everything we're
doing here
was kind of split it was like three days
at red robin double shifts about 32
hours a week
and then hustling on my side hustle
clear vision media my business
making some money from that but to be
honest i just reinvested a lot of it
like you probably do as soon as i would
make money on my business i'd be like oh
crap i'm gonna get this gear i'm gonna
get this lighting you know what i mean
and and because i knew red robin was
covering this
making a little money from my side
hustle this i didn't write this one down
when i started making money from my side
hustle i reinvested it back
into my side hustle if i made money from
my business
or affiliate marketing early on i
invested it back into books or into gear
or into travel or you see what i'm
saying
and so uh these these projects though
they
all align they have this common theme of
video leadership
business right and so i was doing my
best to
align all of those things together so
here's five quick areas where the
proximity principle changed my life
volunteering i told you about that
number two is starting an interview show
because jeff and i started an interview
show back in 2010
we started getting around high level
people
and i won't go into there's a lot of
stories i could go deep into and maybe
let me know if you'd like this to be
like a series or some other things
but one of the people we interviewed was
named dr dave martin who again
proximity principle he was somebody
doing something i wanted to do one day
he was speaking on stages
he was writing books he was creating
courses and training materials
and so i because of that interview show
not only did i get around him at first
but then like no joke like one two years
later i saw him at an event and then
like said hey someday i would love to
like work for you
and he's like okay whatever and then
like another year passed i saw him at
another event and i was like look let me
i can help you with youtube and blah
blah blah
and it worked out and eventually he was
a side client in addition everything
else i was trying to do side freelance
projects
that would get me closer to my goal get
me around
somebody that would level me up because
he's teaching leadership and he's doing
what i want to do in my future the
proximity principle
and now i'm also in proximity to his
content i'm editing his videos i'm
getting wisdom i'm getting knowledge
and i'm getting see and i and i didn't
even care how much money he paid me
because it was the level up man he
didn't actually pay me that good
i mean and i didn't demand more but like
i was just i was doing uh
freelance social media on the side for
him but guess what i'm learning about
facebook i'm learning what content works
what doesn't i'm testing
different headlines i'm getting to level
myself up and make money from it and
get around somebody that is completely
shifting
and transforming my life it came because
of starting an interview show and i'd
say that even to this day
video influencers man it majorly
exploded and blew up our brand
and that one did as well in fact it led
to another
job another career exactly what ken
coleman teaches in his book the
proximity principle
from getting around movers shakers the
ambitious
people that don't have excuses people
that are not critical
you got to get away from people that are
just negative and just
critical i mean it's not going to help
you go full time on youtube just pass
some mystic
pulling you back holding you down and
and
and some of those people are family
members so you still got to spend time
with them and some of those are your
best friend and you still love them
but are you spending enough time around
positive
people and people that are gonna level
you up and move you forward it's a major
life-changing principle the third thing
is freelancing in your niche so i i
wanted to take on
clients and people that would help me
learn more
about youtube so again i never would do
it for very much of a fee
i probably always charged a little bit
too let too little but look
it was that was short i didn't care
about the money man
i think it was a little short-sighted to
worry about now money like i would
rather make baby money now so i can make
big money in 10 years
if that makes sense and so why i wanted
the skills i wanted to level up
and so freelancing for dr dave by the
way
i met benji travis in our small town
because we started think international
and jeff moore started it and we met at
the ymca
and then i found out his wife did
youtube and then i filmed
their engagement video he text me a
couple days later and he's like yo
uh i know we just met because we just
met at the ymca in like 2010.
but i'm going to propose to my
girlfriend judy
could you help me film it yeah you know
and he paid me like
50 bucks and i came over and i filmed it
and then out of that we did a wedding
series together and fast forward
now we have video influencers in a book
together but it all started from
starting an interview show getting out
there now
i'm getting a freelance for them and
they're saying oh by the way i've been
putting in work in youtube i knew
youtube stuff i knew uh ranking and
titling by this time in seo because i'd
been studying i'd been investing in
myself
and so i'm now freelancing for them and
that's
you know kind of the rest is history as
well so these are some major areas
where the proximity principle changed my
life number four is work for free
i know people sometimes hate on that i
guess
the results you know it's worked for me
so i encourage
don't be short-sighted about money now
that's why get your money right
in just some kind of job that you that
you're okay with
like find your red robin the burger
place i worked at find that place
because i was like cool if i can just
kind of pay my bills with this
and live lean then all the stuff that i
want to do i can level up and get the
experience over here
and so i did a lot of work for free a
lot of the work i would get for like a
dr dave or some other people
started with some free work to get their
attention and then moving to las vegas
now you might have limitations i'm sure
just like all of us
on moving and the reason i moved to las
vegas from seattle
an hour north from our small town called
marysville washington
i moved to las vegas because i got a job
working for
a mega church and i'd been working in a
tiny church
and now i was working for church about
2500 people so that leveled me up to a
whole nother level but here's what i
learned
was just like they say in real estate
location location location
man the proc like your location can be a
major needle mover now this this i don't
want this make you like
yeah but like my family's rooted here
you know
you got to move to la to be successful
on youtube that's not what i'm saying
but i am saying are your dreams are you
serious enough about your dreams that
you would be willing to relocate
yourself
i've heard stories of like there's a guy
named grant cardone who's now
built over 1.2 billion dollars in real
estate holdings
and is kind of number two guy i think
the vice president of his company is
named jared glant and jared
literally flew from like california to
miami
slept on an air mattress and
bootstrapped for grant but hey a couple
years later
and his whole life's changed sometimes
it's a radical shock it's taking a major
move
i'm also not guaranteeing that's gonna
like lead to success or not but what i
am saying is location matters and
sometimes
changing your location if not
permanently getting out of your
environment is just a major
key why get around people and places the
proximity principle
when i moved to vegas it was a whole
other level because i also got into an
environment of greater pressure
bigger church more responsibility
more things but i was also around the
lead pastor again
proximity principal was an international
speaker author
i helped him write and launch books
getting ready for launching my own i got
to travel with him a little bit i got to
sit and hear him communicate
in sermons every sunday and guess what
that did for me as a communicator
it leveled me up proximity principle i
mean
majorly i got to speak a few times there
and then i got to get feedback after
what did that do level me up you know
what i'm saying so like how do i get
confidence on
the proximity principle this is just
personal for me
volunteer start an interview show
freelance in your niche work for free
moving to las vegas
all of these things helped me get around
people and in places
that majorly leveled me up which brings
us to step
four which is smart systems
when you're in the side hustle season
and you want to get to the full-time
season well
the full-time season is kind of a dream
because you're like well i'm full-time i
can devote my whole time to it
but right where most of us are now
right watching is in that side hustle
season and juggling 42 other things
while trying to bootstrap and make this
work
the only way i've learned to do it is
smart systems and here's what i mean
in 2011 we moved to las vegas
and i mentioned that and here was kind
of the 2011 to 2014 jobs and pro
projects i'm full-time i have a
full-time job as a church communications
director
i'm doing freelance projects eventually
i'm doing some stuff for dr dave
i still flew back shot benji and judy's
wedding benji
uh and i this is way before video
influencers but he would from time to
time
we would work on uh some brand deals and
i would film some stuff
if it was needed fancy production and my
family was in seattle so i could always
visit my family and make it a work trip
too
and and as i went into my position by
the way
because i had some pre-existing brands i
negotiated
even into that kind of contract i said
look i'm gonna crush it and do my best
and
and and really deliver value here but
it's i'm passionate about freedom
and it was nice you can't always
negotiate that but i was nice
because as i was getting into that job i
had some pre-existing things i brought
it up from the start so it gave me
a little bit of margin for freelance
projects not even much though i'm still
doing it
in my spare time but um and then it was
youtube as a side hustle
so by the time i'm freelancing for
others and i have a full-time job
and i'm trying to do youtube you get it
it's it's hard it's really tough
you're like you're running your you know
circles trying to do all the different
things
and so here's a few tips batch producing
content
i'm not going to go into that here we'll
link some videos in the description
about it
you've heard us talk about batch
producing content it's don't just shoot
one video
shoot four at a time if you can't and
then release one one a week
for uh four weeks and there's a month's
worth of content captured in one day
right and so people go well how do i
batch if i vlog
you don't just don't don't vlog
like do so like i mean you have to build
this thing around your life like if you
always say how can i and there's some
sort of impossibility
we rework your strategy so create
a like almost template create
a show on youtube that is sustainable
makes sense i heard it said once that
the problem with an
unsustainable pace is that it's
unsustainable
right and so like a sustainable pace is
like okay so
to do this and i'm gonna give you some
tips on this but create
literally a plan to say if i only got 10
hours a week to do youtube then here's
what i'm going to do in those 10 hours
have you defined that figure out how
much time a week do you have to do
youtube in fact
tell me right now in the chat how much
time do you have get real honest and
maybe
chicken scratch it out like if you're
really honest
how much time per week
do you have to devote to your youtube
channel some of us
you know you might be on here you're a
single mom and you're like not a lot
that's okay just be realistic about it
and take those
five hours that you're doing after when
the kids go to sleep
and be relentlessly protective of them
to work on your youtube channel
you know um define just get clear
on how much time you have plant-based
ads one to two hours a day
is the time i'm putting into this that's
great a day that's awesome
and and that makes sense i mean you
maybe get home instead of doing x
you and leisure stuff you work on your
side hustle i love it
one hour is that one hour maybe i didn't
say uh
a week so 20 hours devoted so gwen
that's amazing so i would take that 20
hours and then think okay what exactly
am i doing in this
um you know heart shell is 15 hours
every day dude you got 15 hours
you can deploy so much hustle against
that
16 hours a day some people are saying
you know so we're kind of all over but
please define it because
we do ultimately need to be realistic
about this right
and then ranking videos now i'll mention
this a little bit later
but we've talked a lot about ranking
videos that's when
you type in a search term best camera
for youtube and on the other side of the
search term a video shows up
and if that's your video then you get
views while you snooze
the most important aspect i believe of
getting to full time is creating
leverage what do i mean by leverage
creating things that will work for you
when you're not working
so a ranked video is that if you don't
have much time
but you can put out a video that will
get views for weeks months and years to
come
then while i'm at my job and while i'm
freelancing while i'm doing other things
then my youtube channel
is growing and making forward progress
even if it's slow
because of ranked videos so that was
another one we'll touch on that a little
more later and then also be realistic
and embrace life's seasons so i really
mean that
like don't be too hard on yourself if
you're like well i'm full time at
university and i have 15
kids and i have 14 family members living
at my house and
16 jobs how why can't i find time for
youtube
probably because of what i just you know
what i'm saying like so you really need
to be
be realistic and realize life seasons
are different
okay and so um a mistake i made though
and it's a major mistake and i see
i see it as like a pandemic amongst
entrepreneurs and creatives and it's
this doing
too many side projects including youtube
channels at once
so when i have this full-time job and
i'm freelancing we were still doing
think international not a lot but every
once in a while we would go to a
conference shoot some more content
i was uploading stuff on my sean thinks
channel which is like not even a thing
right now
but like we daily vlogged for a while i
mean again i was getting a lot of
experience
my wife and i about killed myself we
daily vlog for almost 50 days
like in the midst of all this but when
we did that there was no think media
videos when we did that there was no
think international
i was spread too thin by by doing too
many things
clear vision media i was still doing
some projects there and then think media
got a video here and there this is no
joke i had four like youtube channels
right around 2011 12 and there was kind
of no
wonder why any of them weren't really
taking off
because if you try and if you try and
chase four rabbits
you'll end up catching none of them and
so these things
were kind of going everywhere now it was
helping me skill up but it was also
causing me a lot of stress
and so what i would encourage you i see
this all the time
i really don't think you should be
working on two youtube channels
especially three or four
and i also don't think you should be
trying to grow a youtube channel if you
want to go full time on youtube
while also like podcasting at some major
level and then you also are trying to
keep your blog up and you're also like
doing a bunch of stuff on your website
and working on random projects because i
was doing all kinds of random stuff like
just trying to make stuff work
but i just wasted so much energy and
time
when you are in the side hustle season
you got to be sniper focused
on what you're doing so if i could do it
all over here's what i would do i would
focus on one youtube channel
i would upload one valuable video a week
and i would do that by doing batching
okay
so i would i would i would be more
focused on like this is how busy my
season is
i needed to sit down and record four
videos and in hindsight it would have
been think media it was the strongest
brand and i was kind of
blind to that because it where people
wanted the video tips but again i was
pulled in all these other directions
because of projects i
started i'll be honest with you i'm good
at starting things i'm actually i really
struggle with stopping things
you know one of the reasons why i think
international i kind of kept it going
with jeff
even though i was in a season where i
probably shouldn't have was because i
had put
my blood my sweat my tears
into it and it was just kind of hard to
let it go but to be honest
you may need to let some things go right
now
so that you could focus on what matters
most to you
the analogy in in um nature is pruning
sometimes you gotta prune the tree which
is painful cutting
off things you're doing cutting off
projects
maybe cutting off relationships i don't
mean in a rude way but like
you just can't if you're giving your
time and your energy away to everybody
else and everything else
then how can you get momentum on your
youtube channel to hit your goal of
going full time
sometimes you gotta prune but when you
prune back it's painful at first and it
actually is almost like shoot now i got
less
but it creates the infrastructure for
you for that
life that plant to flourish that tree to
grow bigger and better than ever before
and so getting really clear focusing on
one youtube channel
uploading one valuable video a week only
using social media to support my youtube
channel when starting
not trying to like oh social media
expert says
igtv is hot well cool and it is and i'm
pumped about it and like it's getting
more views now because it's in the news
feed
but you can't do freaking everything
when you're in your side hustle
so i would use social media to support
my youtube channel but i'll be focused
all on that youtube channel
see i was like trying to dabble
everywhere and if you're if you're
dabbling everywhere then you're
dominating nowhere
right and so then i'd also cut out
distractions cut out just little fringy
things
and get hyper focused if i could do it
all over because here's the good news
i'm telling you this journey of 2010 to
basically now
end this path to full time friend i
think you can get there way faster
our commitment here at think media is
our mission is to help 10 000 people
create a full-time living doing what
they love
and making a difference using online
video
and we've had tons of stories already of
people that are doing that whether
they've
been going through our content or our
like academies like our video ranking
academy or these different things
and um and so
our passion and belief is that while we
don't believe in overnight success
we really believe we can shave 75
off of your journey like my journey
which actually starts in 2003
is all of this pain and weird roads and
distractions and doing way too many
projects
i'm here that's what this training is
about is so you could go further faster
and and so if you were to take 75 off of
a 10-year journey
it's still going to take like two and a
half years i just want to shoot straight
with you
some of us will go faster some of us is
going to take three or four or five
years
some it's going to take seven but no
matter what like if you were set on your
goal
how worth it is you like how worth it is
it to you like
you get obsessed to say like i will
until and maybe there's a light bulb for
some of you that's like
shoot man shawn's got like a couple
other youtube channels that didn't work
out
and he was willing to prune to focus on
the youtube channels that are working
now
thank god for the experience i learned
on those other channels
but i had to let them go maybe
reposition myself out of a different
niche
reposition myself focus on one thing and
that might be a key for you
to breaking through and finally building
the momentum you want on youtube
and so here's a great reason why think
media
didn't start growing until it did and by
the way youtube analytics is a little
sketchy in the uploads i definitely
uploaded videos between 2010 and 2013
which is what you see over here
they just don't register in old
analytics for some reason but here's the
gist
when did all this blue and think media
start to blow up and grow to over 800
000 subscribers when did that happen
it happened when i started uploading
videos like
i mean that's what the graph shows like
uh
if you want to succeed on youtube you
gotta upload videos on youtube
thank you everybody have a great night
you know what i mean but i mean like
that's like so true uh that that's what
you ultimately have to do and you can
see it that when i got consistent
and started posting it started to go up
go up go up go up
and so in hindsight i'm like dang i knew
a lot about you i'm helping other people
grow their channels i'm doing a lot of
other things
but i'd spread myself so thin it delayed
my progress
massively and so when i started posting
videos on youtube that's when the
results came
remember focus stands for follow one
course
until successful get clear get focused
niche down and follow one course
until successful hey if you're getting
value out of this video can you smash
the like button tyler thanks for the
super chat hey gerald thanks for the
super chat marie
thanks for the super chat focus
follow one course until
successful okay and so you might be
doing too much you probably are
even in your side house your side hustle
time is so precious a lot of you said i
got five hours
i got like one hour you know a day i got
like 10 or 15 hours
you got to get sniper on the time you
have
to be focused on the just minimum
effective dose
and then deploy that and that's how
you're going to get to full time
faster well that was step number three
and four
synergizing your schedule and creating
smart systems and thinking about
what it's like to work for free that's
actually how i got started here at think
media you know it's really important to
me to
give value before asking for value and
what that looked like for me was i had
been in a season where i had been
working with different small businesses
i actually had my own digital agency at
the time but i knew i needed to get into
video
so i sent shawn a tweet when my family
and i moved
to the same location where he lived and
i said hey i've got some skills i know
you understand video i'd love to learn
from you and i would love
to intern yep that's right i started
working here
at think as an intern i brought the
skills that i had the experience that i
had
but instead of asking for monetary value
i
decided to just give without expectation
now it worked out because
in our meeting that sean and i had he
said hey i love all the things you're
doing i can't pay you
but as an entrepreneur i knew that i
wanted to be a part of this mission
i saw that he had big vision and big
goals and i knew that
my vision could fit with inside that and
so i started working for free
i did months of free work for sean and
we developed our first
academy which is video ranking academy
through that we actually did a profit
sharing so instead of paying me upfront
he just started paying me when we
started making money
and it's worked out since then now i'm
the host of the think marketing podcast
and we've built a whole team around us
but it wouldn't have happened
if i didn't step out and work for free
so when you think about synergizing your
schedule when you think about
getting in the room in proximity of the
right people
really think about what's the value you
can give what skills do you have
or what things can you offer and bring
to the table
that's something i challenge you with if
you're not yet in the role that you want
to be in
how can you get there who can you get
around what podcast
can you be listening to like this one
what books can you be reading
what people can you surround yourself
with you know i think about other people
on the think
media team here at think they started as
interns because they believed in what we
were doing
so proximity principle it works i am a
living testament to saying
that it works and when you think about
those smart systems
man if you don't know my story i am a
homeschooling mom of three
kids two middle schoolers and one
elementary school and i do this
full-time
so not only do i homeschool but i also
create content here for think
as well as having a homeschool channel
now how do you do smart systems
in a season where you may not be able to
devote as much time
i think it's really important if you are
in a season where you don't feel like
you have time
that you actually start to evaluate it
one of the practices that i did was
for every 15 minutes of the day i wrote
down what i was doing
i did this for a whole week so i could
actually see what i was spending my time
on
you know what's embarrassing i was
spending a lot of time on social media
on instagram reading blogs
doing the work but not actually doing
the work
and so when i started to see what was on
my calendar
i was able to then start to block out
the right amount of time that i needed
i would write scripts after the kids
went to bed or
i would work on client work in the
morning before they woke up
i created a calendar calendar blocking
system that helped me
really understand what was important you
know one of the quotes i love from a
book
that really changed my life essentialism
is if you don't prioritize
your time someone else will you'll hear
me say that over and over here
on the podcast because i think your time
is so important
so if you feel like you're in a season
where maybe you have kids or you have a
second job or
you're caring for an elderly parent
maybe you don't feel like you quite have
the time to do this
i want to challenge you this week write
down every 15 minutes
what are you doing with your time and
then take that
evaluate it and change it because you're
the one that's going to make the change
to make your dreams come true
so that is the next two steps and i'm
excited to get into
next episode where we're gonna be
finishing off these
seven steps if you've been getting value
out of this make sure you subscribe and
if you can't wait for the next episode
to come out and you want to know what
your next step is
maybe it's to take our free youtube
class if you haven't taken this for
youtube class it's a one hour class
that sean cannell the ceo of think media
walks through
the three secrets for winning on youtube
he dives into
why it's not too late to start on
youtube and
how to break through how to get
discovered and how to start youtube
right if you felt lost or you felt like
you don't really know how this whole
youtube thing works
we're here to help you think media is
put in the time and the energy
we're always testing with not just this
channel but all of our channels that we
manage
and we know what works and how to help
you break through
so you can go to thinkmasterclass.com if
that's your next step
and what i love so much about going
through
this class is that we give you the
opportunity to
join us inside of our academy video
ranking academy like i said was the
first academy that we created
and we've now helped hundreds of people
go full time
doing the exact thing that we teach on
this free class
so you're going to want to make sure
that you watch that free class while
it's available
it's brand new and updated and waiting
for you at thinkmasterclass.com
if you have loved this podcast i
encourage you to share it with someone
who
needs to learn youtube this is again a
three-part series and i'll bet you have
someone in your life
right now who is wanting to learn
youtube so make sure that you share this
podcast
with them to help them go full time as
well
and if you're listening right now on
itunes i encourage you to subscribe
and you can also rate and review the
podcast it helps itunes
let other people know that this podcast
is one that they should listen to
and today i'd love to read the review
from blazing video he says
love it stop thinking and just subscribe
just love how their content is so real
found
sean cannell on another podcast and now
i've subscribed bought their book
have their audiobook and subscribe on
youtube
just fantastic and relevant content well
blazing video thank you so much for
being a part of our community
it means so much to us to have you
rating and reviewing and and giving your
testimonies online
of how this has impacted you i think one
of my favorite things is being able to
read these reviews and to connect with
you on social media so if you have liked
this podcast
let us know how has it helped you what
tip was the tip that changed what you
were doing
i'd love to know what was it that helped
you the most
alright in next week's episode we're
going to finish this
series off part three and we're going to
be talking about the last three steps
finding your sweet spot helping you
decide your side income streams and
knowing when to step out you know it
sounds great to say go
full time on youtube but when do you
actually make the jump
if you have a full-time job right now or
you're ready to
move into a full-time role on youtube
when do you actually
go full-time what does that look like
and how do you actually mathematically
calculate
when is the right time for you to make
that leap i can't wait to see you on the
next episode and again
share this with a friend subscribe rate
and review and we'll see you on the next
podcast
you